Donald Trump's cabinet and group of
advisers is well on its way to being the
most deplorable ridiculous vile depraved
and laughable of the last hundred plus
years we've got four billionaires for
there are 540 billionaires in the United
States 540 that's it just 540 in a
country of 350 million people four of
them nearly 1% of them are going to be
in Donald Trump's cabinet we have three
generals who are going to be in Donald
Trump's cabinet of course under 1% of
the American population serving in the
military we are going to have three
individuals from the military in Donald
Trump's cabinet the Secretary of State
is going to be Exxon CEO Rex Tillerson a
guy who has fundamentally destroyed our
planet by drilling for oil with
decades-long connections to Russia
Donald Trump ran against Hillary Clinton
because she was the bad Wall Street
schmoozer who won't tell us about her
Wall Street speeches and it turns out
that former Goldman Sachs partner Steve
minuchin is going to be the Treasury
secretary talked about bamboozling your
own voters and then of course you've got
Wilbur Ross a private equity financier
who made a fortune buying bankrupt
companies and flipping them for profits
for Secretary of Commerce and then one
of the women in Trump's cabinet
Education Secretary Betsy DeVos she's
gonna be running education Pat she's
against funding public schools in
principle yeah I mean it's been one
unqualified deeply conflicted pick after
another and if when you look at the the
blue-collar white workers that really
push Donald Trump over the edge yeah how
are they gonna be happy with any of
these picks well they'll be happy
because they'll think that Trump has
their best interests in mind they just
won't benefit from it in any way you can
add to the list billionaire Chicago Cubs
owner a co-owner Todd Ricketts Deputy
Secretary of Commerce another
billionaire and then you've got Trump's
national security adviser retired
General Michael Flynn former military
intelligence chief who sees no
difference between radical Islam and
most Muslims has
parroted outrageous internet conspiracy
theories and then don't forget waiting
in the wings there is Attorney General
Jeff session soon to be attorney general
Jeff sessions who liked the Ku Klux Klan
until you found out that they smoked
weed sometimes and thinks that you
fundamentally cannot be a good person if
you smoke weed he wants to scale up the
embarrassingly failed war on drugs and
then we get to congressman and former
orthopedic surgeon Tom Price who wants
to get rid of Obamacare is anti choice
in a world where we have the highest
support for legal abortion in the
history of the United States is anti gay
marriage when we should be considering
that a completely settled issue a total
1950s retrograde lunatic and then
closing it out scott pruett will be
leading the EPA not a cabinet position
but typically considered an equivalent
rank to cabinet-level positions longtime
pro fossil fuel dude who denies humans
have any impact on climate change in
other words a non science buffoon and
then the cherry on top as I like to call
it ben Carson a neurosurgeon who
actually said I'm not qualified enough
to be involved in Trump's cabinet will
be Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development chopping off I mean that if
you talk about a deplorable cake of
unqualified buffoons
ben Carson really is the cherry on top
is a that is the cherry yeah I mean it's
a full diverse range of people though
you have goldman sachs financier you
have climate change deniers heads of oil
companies yeah it's the full range oil
billionaires and equity private equity
billionaires none of these people are
going to do anything to help middle
america now if they do something to help
themselves which by coincidence actually
has the side effect of helping middle
america then they'll allow it but that's
as far as you're going to get in terms
of them doing anything that is going to
help the average person who will really
benefit from one of donald trump's
estate tax proposals people on his
cabinet and his advisers Trump has the
idea of repealing the estate tax and
that is something that would be really
really good financially to the people
that Donald Trump is picking to
represent him or
around the world and in different
departments of government this cabinet
really makes the George W Bush cabinet
seemed like a pretty well qualified and
well reasoned group of people which is
insane Pat but I actually think back to
the Bush cabinet and I think you know it
really wasn't bad compared to this clown
car that Donald Trump is putting
together unfortunately there is some
crossover there though because John
Bolton's going to be the Deputy
Secretary of State yep John Bolton of
course the guy who was ambassador to the
UN yet didn't really think that we
should have a United Nations and was he
involved
I know Michael Chertoff was involved
financially with the porno scanner
Airport machines but I don't remember if
John Bolton was also involved with that
anyway III do you remember offhand we're
gonna have to look into that one yeah I
don't remember Michael Chertoff
certainly and I guess Michael Chertoff
won't be part of the Trump
administration but maybe he will you
know never too far behind a lot of
discussion about these selections and
others happening on our reddit
discussion forum which you can check out
at david pakman.com slash read it that's
our EDD IT over 2100 of our viewers and
listeners regularly participating in
discussion there please subscribe there
and participate a lot of good stuff
going on and I'm on there daily you also
check that out I know do you comment
down there your what are you T DPS Pat
yes people go crazy whenever I post
something because that is among us yeah
well you know I could I could see that
TDPS Pat is on there I believe my user
name is David Pakman on reddit it's all
happening at david pakman.com slash
reddit Warby Parker is offering a free
five day home Tryon to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses I
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of 5 pairs of
glasses you can get your free home try
on and support the david pakman show at
Warby Parker trialed comm slash TDP s I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home
Aion I was able to pick five pairs that
I liked put them on in the comfort of my
own home pick the one I like the most
and then Warby Parker put my
prescription lenses in there for me a
lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing